you know I've often heard writers
actually not writers people who want to
be writers say oh I can't possibly read
while I'm writing because I'm afraid
that it will rub off on me and I'll
start to it and I always think oh you
know how terrifying I might sound like
Tolstoy or a check off or you know oh no
no I don't think that you know certainly
I think when you start out writing when
anybody starts out writing you start out
imitative Lee they're writers you admire
and you start out consciously or
unconsciously imitating those writers
but eventually you grow out of that and
develop your own Sensibility really so
and in terms of research for nonfiction
books fortunately unfortunately I don't
have that great of memory certainly not
anymore so I'm so I'm never worried
about remembering too much that that
doesn't happen like every writer I had a
great high school English teacher but I
had a really bad junior high school
English teacher when she wasn't bad she
was probably great I just didn't like
her and she assigned us to copy over
word-for-word a check up a short Chekhov
story I can it's the one where that
guy's talking to the horse so he tells
his horse the whole story
and so we had to copy it over and we
were all just in a rage about it you
know what a waste of our time that it
ended but actually I think it was very
useful and in fact when I was writing
reading like a writer in which they're
huge blocks of quotes from other writers
and because I have no technological
ability whatsoever I couldn't figure out
how to scan anything so in some cases I
had to type whole pages of other writers
into the manuscript so and I would
notice that my writing got briefly
better after I had copied literally
copied I mean copying this hundred and
eighty one word sentence from Virginia
Woolf my writing sounded a little bit
more like Virginia Woolf afterwards
which is a good thing so so I think that
can be very useful
I wish I read more I mean when I was a
kid I was that's all I did that's you
know four years and then when you're in
college if you're an English major as I
was you know you'll have a week where
you have to read four Victorian novels
by the initely you know reading this
huge amount now I know unfortunately in
my life is so overwhelmingly crammed
with stuff that that it's very hard to
find that time to just read for pleasure
and also because I still review quite a
bit
often the books I'm reading our books
that I'm reading for work early but but
every so often I get a chance to read
something just to read something I mean
I was traveling a lot in the spring and
I read Little Dorrit Dickens Little
Dorrit and I just loved it I just
couldn't believe as a number of us were
reading Little Dorrit actually friends
of mine because um I guess there was a
PBS series there was a dramatization and
and a couple of my friends said oh I
don't really want to watch the TV show
let's read it and you know we don't have
a reading group or anything but just you
know people I knew were reading it and a
friend of mine said who would have
thought that Dickens has been underrated
all this time it was so great and the
joy of reading it was extraordinary so
you know every so often that happens
I'm always shocked and believe me it
happens more than you can imagine to
meet young writers graduate students who
don't read or don't read anything
written before the last 50 years or
don't see why they should read the
classics or and I just can't understand
why they want to be writers why what
would be the point
really
yeah how could I not well although you
know the novelist Richard price has this
great thing that he says or I heard him
say which was you know people are always
talking about the death of the novel the
death of novel and he says the novel
will be around at our funeral and it's
true you know there's still you know I
was just this weekend I was at the
Brooklyn Book Festival it was jammed
there were hundreds of people there you
know people with baby strollers and
readers and writers and it was Jim so
clearly somebody is still reading I mean
I can't figure out there were you know I
guess there are a couple of musicians
there there were no movie stars that I
noticed so somebody had to be there to
see writers
well just simply I like writing both but
also I'm not you know there's some read
some writers well Philip Roth comes to
mind for example who can at this point
finish a novel and as far as I can tell
start another novel and and with no
decline in quality really who can just
keep turning out these fabulous novels
but I can't do that I mean I need time
after a novel relate to write another
novel just even think about another
novel non-fiction is great in that way
and that you can you don't need the same
kind of inspiration really you can just
write and I like to write I'm gonna have
to say I like the act of writing I like
writing so so I'm able to keep writing
without depending on on all the sorts of
things that you can't control I mean the
imagination or all the things that go
into a novel you know writing nonfiction
you have a certain amount of information
and you put that information together
and tell a story as you would in a novel
but but it's not you can control it I
mean you don't you don't you can pretty
much always finish a work of nonfiction
I mean I've I've stopped novels in the
middle because they are not going
anywhere this has never happened to me
it's with nonfiction
well unfortunately not I mean Here I am
I'm not gonna write today but but when I
can you know for I mean for example this
summer I wrote every day pretty much
every day you know the summers are great
I mean I can work in the card and so and
right so so over the summer I wrote
every day and in and if I had my if I
could choose my life I would be writing
every day but but no one can really or
very few people can so I actually have
the life in addition to having a writing
life and and their various things that I
have to do and want to do because of the
life I'm living in addition to the
writing life so so no I don't
I wish I did I you know I used to I used
to be kind of snooty about it I used to
say things like well I'm not that
interested in myself you know one
another now I wish I did because as I
remember fewer and fewer things that
happened to me I wish I had this source
that I could go to because often it
happens that people say remember we were
having dinner at blah blah and somebody
says it and it's as if it never happened
so I would like to have some some
reference to be able to go to but no i
don't i keep notebooks
oh sure yeah they're there you know they
range from just fascinating to
inspirational I mean check offs
notebooks are great dusty-ass Keys
notebooks are interesting you know his
struggle to write crime and punishment
is all in there or and then the letters
I mean the letters of Flannery O'Connor
are particularly amazing and
inspirational because you know she was
so ill for so much of her life and her
determination I mean there's this
fantastic section where I was and her
mother persuades her I think to go to
Lourdes to look for a cure really
because she was so ill and she goes to
Lourdes and I think prays for her like
her second novel to work out well you
know so that kind of dedication and her
humor and her courage and her
intelligence as or Elisabeth bishops
letters and you know you I mean for one
thing you learn a great deal about the
process of writing and and second you
just it's such an intimate connection
with the writer
I was such a big reader when I was a kid
so it could have been it could have
started anywhere you know Louisa May
Alcott maybe
hands Christian Anderson possibly I
remember very clearly reading Garcia
Marquez a hundred years of solitude when
I was maybe a couple of years out of
college and and you know my work is
nothing like RC Marquez obviously but
but the sense of the pleasure of
storytelling and how fun it would be to
have a story in which things come back
and reappear and plot turns and dadada I
had a huge effect on me I thought oh
that sounds like fun
yeah although I mean I have I have lots
of friends who are writers who were
around my age so I think of us as a
generation of writers just because we're
writers and we're a generation but I
don't I'm not sure you know maybe at
some other time someone will say oh yes
there's this connection among us I mean
you are formed by the period during what
you grew up so there is a certain
sensibility politically even though this
may not come out in the work socially
again may not come out in the work about
how we view the world that I think is is
a connection but but people's work it's
so different from from you know in a way
that it's supposed to be we're supposed
to be completely unlike anyone else
that's kind of at the point really
I'll let you know when it happens you
know it doesn't I mean I you know you
were asking before about um about is
there a generation of writers and you
know somewhat well one of the reasons
that I feel so fortunate to have close
friends who are writers is that we can
on some level you know the the intensity
of self doubt and uncertainty and you
know a friend of mine says well you
never know if anything's good until the
last sentence of the last paragraph or
the last draft I mean that you know and
and and you if you're writing a novel
let's say you could be working for four
years without anyone looking at what
you're doing so so at some point you
know at some point I'll look at every so
often I'll look back at something else
I've done and say oh yeah I'm a writer
this is really good but but in those
moments are rare still